you can see them in every Canadian
neighborhood kids with their noses up
against the glass peering out of the
world they no longer understand
wondering what happened to their lives
parks and playgrounds are closed the
news is all about frightening stories of
a mysterious virus and all the sick and
dying people and as Jeff sample explains
children have lots and lots of questions
like a lot of kids Breanna and Bryson
have been stuck at home for weeks
finding creative ways to pass the time
[Music]
that's cool
hold them up let me see those look great
how does it feel being at home for so
long they're growing bored and a bit
worried about this virus everyone's
talking about child psychologists say
that's important News asked kids to send
us their Topco vid 19 questions Bryson
wanted to know about his grandma nursing
wise why can't I have my grandma so we
put his question and others to the
experts you might be passing on the
virus to her and we know that people
especially grandmas and grandpas usually
get a lot sicker than maybe young people
do in fact most young people who've
gotten the virus have done a great job
fighting it
how did Coby maintains that experts
aren't actually sure but they think the
virus started in a bat in China
occasionally the viruses can pass from a
bat to another animal perhaps through a
bite or some secretions from the nose of
the bat and then sometimes that animal
will pass the virus to humans my
question
another planet and is kovin 19 on the
hairbrush it's certainly possible if you
were to cough into your head and then
touch your hairbrush the virus could
pass from your hands to the hairbrush as
for other planets experts don't think
kovat 19 could survive in space but some
corona viruses can live in freezing
temperatures for up to two years kovat
19's germs can survive on some surfaces
like a plastic toy for up to three days
the virus doesn't jump so it doesn't go
from a toy into your nose the only way
you can get this if you touch it and
then touch your mouth and nose
what's your name gonna be
oh man how long till I go tour friend's
housing grandma's house again
unfortunately experts say it's not a
matter of minutes but weeks I do think
that these physical distancing measures
are going to last for at least another
six to eight weeks if not longer
but then if everyone does their part
Bryson and his sister will get to visit
grandma again very soon
my
[Music]